nevada highway patrol says the popular  owner of lee's discount liquor was not  wearing a seat belt in the crash that  took his life 53 year old kenny lee died  friday in northern nevada on u.s 93  about halfway between ely and west  wendover investigators say his van  crossed the center line and hit a pickup  truck the other driver had minor  injuries  the company is planning a memorial for  kenny lee it's going to be friday  morning at 9 30 at the leeds discount  liquor location which is at azure and  tanaya which is roughly just east of the  centennial bowl and the public is  invited to share stories and write  messages of support onto one of 500  balloons that will be released in lee's  memory